these look like scenes from a movie or
possibly a real-life emergency situation
but these are merely mock scenarios part
of taiwan testing its readiness to
respond to natural disasters
and missile attacks
the drills have been modified to prepare
emergency services and citizens for
possible assault by china
the feature of this year's drill is we
incorporated wartime scenarios scenes
from the russia-ukraine war and also
simulated china's attacks on taiwan
russia's invasion of ukraine has the
taiwanese government worried that china
could launch a similar assault in the
future
chinese fighter jets have entered
taiwan's air defense identification
zones multiple times this year and act
taipei views as a military provocation
the two split during a civil war in 1949
but beijing sees the island as part of
its territory to be taken by force if
necessary
[Music]
we keep strengthening our combat
abilities in the hopes that we have the
ability to defend ourselves and rescue
others in case there comes a day that we
are faced with a situation of war
a thousand eight hundred police officers
firefighters and volunteers were
involved in the simulation
later this month taiwan will hold its
annual han guang military drills which
involve live fire training
florence louis al jazeera